l'instant est historique il est surtout
empreint d'émotion leurs yeux sont
rouges
il n'ose y croire la cour vient non
seulement de confirmer la condamnation
du chru
mais elle a aussi élargi le nombre des
victimes exposées à l'amiante
l'attention se relâche enfin après huit
années de combat je sais pas ce qu'on
pensait mes collègues et moi sur le coup
je me demandais si j'étais bien là si
j'entends bien s'il entendait bien à ce
moment là c'est vrai que encore une fois
il ya eu tellement d'implication il ya
eu tellement de d'acteur dans tout ça
donc vraiment tous ceux qui ont
participé à sa doivent être aujourd'hui
pour les mots manquent tôt victime mais
ceux de la justice sont parfaitement
clairs oui
l'hôpital est coupable d'avoir exposé
délibérément ses salariés un risque de
mort qu'il ne pouvait ignorer
oui toutes les parties civiles sont
fondés à faire valoir leurs droits le
soulagement est immense pour celles et
ceux qui ont osé l'impensable attaqué
leur direction ça représente la
reconnaissance du statut de victime de
tous les agents même ceux j'allais dire
qu'il n'était pas dans cette procédure
mais symboliquement qui ont été exposés
à l'amiante dans un grand établissement
public et le chu de besançon c'est une
première en france
et c'est vraiment une question décision
qui va faire jurisprudence je l'espère
nous prendrons connaissance sereinement
de la motivation de cet arrêt je crois
qu'il faut rester dans une grande
sérénité sur cette situation
et bien évidemment le chu va
sérieusement envisager de former un
pourvoi en cassation compte tenu des
questions de principe qui se posent dans
cette affaire les pilotes n'est donc
peut être pas encore écrit et tandis que
les travaux se poursuivent dans la
tourmente jo les salariés exposés savent
qu'ils vont désormais devoir gérer
l'après moi j'essaye de pas forcément
pensez ce qui peut nous arriver sur le
plan médical mais forcément celle à quoi
il ya des petites griffes de temps en
temps qui prennent une ampleur
impossible selon l'association nationale
de défense des victimes de l'amiante
l'amiante tué 12 personnes par jour en
france une toutes les deux heures